madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi 3 décembre
nicolas sarkozy en algérie pour une
visite d'état de trois jours il y avait
déclaré je cite le système colonial a
été profondément injuste
la mort d'une petite fille de 8 ans de
hemani qui auraient été pendant de longs
mois maltraité raillé dans son école la
famille pense que leur fille a pu
indirectement succombé à cette
accumulation de stress d'angoissé et du
coup libéré le travail pour libérer le
bout à la chasse est le nouveau credo
gouvernementale différentes mesures vont
être mises en place pour inciter à la
flexibilité et augmenter les routes mais
les restos du coeur lancent aujourd'hui
leur 23e campagne depuis leur création
par coluche en 1985 un milliard de repas
ont été distribués à une population de
plus en plus nombreuses
la victoire de vladimir poutine aux
élections législatives sème le trouble
dans les pays occidentaux de l'europe
aux états unis on s'inquiète de la
mainmise d'un seul homme sur le pays et
puis ce soir notre avis t il peut parler
de tout surtout il nous l'a prouvé le
progrès encore nicolas canteloup est
avec temps à l'occasion de la sortie de
son dvd y sera aussi présent à l'olympia
pendant trois semaines en avril
nicolas sarkozy est donc arrivé cet
après midi à alger pour une visite
d'état de trois jours en voyage qui se
déroule dans un climat pour le moins
particulier après les déclarations
antisémites n'a ministre algérien est
alors que l'opinion publique sur place
attend toujours de la france qu'elle
s'explique
le président de la république a déclaré
ce soir que le système colonial était
contraire aux principes fondateurs de
notre république sur place
michaël darmon et stéphane guillemot
comme de vieux amis qui se retrouvent
je suis content de te revoir dit nicolas
sarkozy abdelaziz bouteflika il étouffe
de baisers les deux hommes politiques
connaissent bien leur métier
dès les premiers pas sur le sol algérien
tout est fait pour effacer la tension de
ces derniers jours le chef de l'état
présente lui-même sa délégation
en algérie nicolas sarkozy est en voyage
d'affaires 5 milliards d'euros de
contrats devraient se signé pendant
cette visite
mais entre les deux pays les relations
politiques sont toujours délicates car
ici le passé colonial ne passe pas et
dans les rues d'alger on aussi entre
pragmatisme et rocker c'est oublier le
passé d'ancien dans le côté à ne pas
générer la violence et la haine entre
les deux peuples à gérer a besoin des
excuses pour de la france pour l'âge à
alger comme à paris on dit attendre
beaucoup de cette visite d'état pour
apaiser les relations passionnelles
entre l'algérie et la france
bon c'est un week-end par mois alors
vous êtes en direct d'alger quelques llc
une ambiance le climat ce matin la
presse algérienne était plutôt critique
ça a évolué vers vous savez si alger on
s'efforce de tenir le même langage
pragmatique qu'à paris pour tenir on
instaurer des relations économiques on
sent bien que les blessures ont loin
d'avoir disparu il suffit de lire la
presse et de rencontrer algérien pour
s'en apercevoir un seul exemple pour
comprendre cette situation le chanteur
enrico macias très populaire ici en
algérie avait prévu était invité donc de
nicolas sarkozy avec la bénédiction de
du président bouteflika et il a dû
renoncer donc à sa visite en algérie
alors en ce moment même où nicolas
sarkozy devant des hommes d'affaires
vient d'expliquer que le système
colonial français avait été profondément
injuste il avait déjà dit en 2006 il
n'ira pas plus loin ce n'est pas pour
lui de la repentance et c'est cette
formule qui comptent dérouler toutes ces
trois jours pendant cette visite ou
qu'on laquelle la france et l'algérie
voudrait se regarder face à face merci
michael d'armand et si le président
sarkozy s'est fait accompagner en a géré
par une centaine de chefs d'entreprises
français c'est aussi parce que le marché
algérien connaît une croissance
considérable la france reste le premier
fournisseur et partenaire de l'algérie
mais les chinois sont aujourd'hui
présents avec il est vrai des prix
extrêmement compétitifs comme le montre
ce reportage de sa masse ou là et abdel
zoud yaiche
pause déjeuner sur le chantier on
pourrait se croire à shanghai ou pékin
mais nous sommes au coeur d'alger un des
plus grands chantiers de la capitale
c'est une entreprise chinoise qui a
remporté l'appel d'offres 900 ouvriers
100% chinois va très vite
ça va très vite là on vient de finir le
gros up sur ce chantier
le chantier du futur siège du ministère
des affaires étrangères et une produit
du très très bon béton car absolument
rien à envier à ce qui se produit en
europe depuis près de cinq ans les
compagnies chinoises raflent tous les
contrats au détriment des entreprises
françaises toujours plus vite et moins
cher
la clé de la réussite la boîte à l'écart
de la société algérie goal un des
nombreux campements d'ouvriers chinois
les conditions de vie sont sommaires
l'organisation quasi militaire ici la
question des heures de travail et des
jours de repos est tabou mais personne
pour se plaint regardez c'est plutôt
bien pour quelqu'un qui travaille à
l'étranger
bon là c'est comme ci comme ça qu'à onze
mètres carrés pour tard selon la rumeur
les chinois seraient payés huit fois
plus que la main d'oeuvre locale en
réalité à peine deux fois plus mais cela
suffit à exaspérer les ouvriers
algériens souvent embauchés à la journée
ou à la semaine sur des chantiers bien
plus modeste pourquoi ils les font venir
alors que nous on est là c'est pas
normal qu'on donne un contrat aux
chinois regarder les jeunes ici il
travaille un jour mais après rien il n'y
a pas que dans le bâtiment que la
présence chinoise agace une fois les
chantiers terminés beaucoup restent là
où il ya quelques temps encore la mode
française faisait fureur des textiles
chinois a pris le pas il importe plus en
marchandises de chiny la bande à très
bas prix
on est toujours obligé de s'aligner en
quelques années les chinois ont réussi à
tisser leur toile dans une société
algérienne qui les observent s'intégrer
me craintive ni admiratif ils ont pris
une ampleur se ranger à l'aéroport
d'alger un nouveau groupe d'ouvriers
vient de débarquer cela viennent
construire l'autoroute qui doit relier
l'est à l'ouest
un autre chantier raflé aux européens ce
sont aujourd'hui des centaines de
chantiers qui sont réalisés par les
chinois à travers l'algérie après des
années d'immobilisme
il faut mettre les bouchées doubles pour
rattraper le temps perdu à perpignan
deux enquêtes ont été ouvertes ce matin
après le décès d'une petite fille de 8
ans noélanie une fille est née à tahiti
adopté par une famille du roussillon
elle était devenue la tête de turc de
plusieurs autres enfants à l'école qui
l'aurait frappé insulté et même
étranglée elle avait écrit pour faire
part de ses angoisses un éducateur de
l'école
mais c'est après sa mort à l'issue d'une
crise de stress que ses parents ont
découvert dans son journal intime
le détail de ces souffrances pierre
monet gier et gilles ruffine noélanie
allait avoir neuf ans elle est morte il
ya deux semaines sa famille est
persuadée qu'elle a succombé à des
lésions causées par des camarades de
classe dont la fillette se plaignait
dans son journal intime
il adore pas à cause de tout ça ce qui
m'a étranglé que j'ai fait tomber dans
les pommes il m'a donné des coups de
pied dans le corps pour me réveiller et
c'est pour de vrai aussi la cantine je
n'arrive pas à manger j'ai peur de lui
lui c'est l'un de ses camarades qui avec
d'autres l'aurait frappée et étranglée à
de multiples reprises pendant une année
noélanie sans plainte une première fois
en octobre 2006 un psychiatre conclut
qu'elle est bien victime de racket avec
racisme et violences et fait un
signalement mais la plainte des parents
est classée sans suite noélanie
s'enferment dans le silence ma fille
était persuadé que réellement
eh ben
d'autres enfants ont le droit d'attenter
à sa vie quand elle n'a pas été protégé
noélanie change d'école mais là son
calvaire aurait continué selon l'un de
ses rares amis s'approcher et on lui dit
01 dégage t il n'a plus tout est noir
alors moi je suis allé à vatel et tu as
vu des gens qui venaient faisait du mal
aussi
oui une fois elle a été troublée c'est
également ce qu'atteste ce certificat
médical le directeur de l'école n'a pas
souhaité nous répondre au téléphone
l'inspectrice d'académie du secteur
affirment que la fillette n'avait pas le
comportement d'une enfant maltraité
l'autopsié a permis d'écarter
l'hypothèse de violences parentales
y at il un lien entre les strangulation
qu'auraient subies noélanie et sa mort à
l'heure actuelle rien ne permet de
l'affirmer
on peut effectivement envisager
l'hypothèse de violences subies par
l'enfant
on peut aussi envisager l'hypothèse
d'une maladie dont l'enfant souffrait je
crois que tout reste à vérifier
il faut attendre les conclusions des
médecins légistes noélanie a été enterré
samedi 200 personnes assistaient aux
obsèques en gironde à cadaujac une femme
âgée de 43 ans qui accompagnait de
collégienne de 13 ans a franchi les
barrières du passage à niveau barrière
qui était fermé un ter a percuté la
voiture elles ont été tuées toutes les
trois david bazié et bernard von arx
le choc a été extrêmement violent tuant
sur le coup la conductrice et ses deux
jeunes passagères en route pour le
collège dès les premières constatations
sur le passage à niveau
le substitut du procureur évoque
l'hypothèse d'une imprudence les
barrières du passage à niveau avait
parfaitement fonctionné et se trouvait
en position b c
dans le cas d'un évitement ce barrière
éventuellement mais il faut demeurer
très prudent sur les circonstances mais
depuis les gendarmes ont recueilli un
témoignage oculaire qui confirmerait que
la voiture a tenté de contourner les
barrières
c'est aussi le sentiment de ce riverain
sorti de chez lui quelques secondes
après l'accident il a dû prendre la
voiture dernier moment où l'un comme
l'autre se sont rencontrés la 3 journée
c'est qu'elle a été basculé une dizaine
de mètres elle devait pas être
totalement engagés aussi le train avait
eu une indication quelconque on aurait
entendu soient vaccinés soit ralentir
selon réseau ferré de france
aucun accident corporel ne s'est produit
depuis 20 ans à cet endroit
le passage à niveau n'est pas classé
comme dangereux c'est la première fois
que je vois un signe aussi grave
il est certain que les passages à niveau
et donc à naujac y en a quatre
c'est le plus emprunté mais c'est vrai
que jusqu'à présent les biens y avait
les disciplines des usagers qui fait que
la pression faire attention car même
protégé un passage à niveau est toujours
dangereux
le premier ministre françois fillon a
plaidé à nouveau pour la flexibilité
dans le temps de travail seule façon
selon lui de libérer le pouvoir d'achat
pour lequel à cette nombre de
dispositions sont prévues au total 12
milliards d'euros seraient ainsi
injectés dans l'économie
les explications de syriza et damien
louvet
pour françois fillon l'équation est
simple la hausse du pouvoir d'achat
passera d'abord par la libéralisation du
travail
nous voulons créer une véritable
flexsécurité à la française c'est à dire
d'un côté rendre le marché du travail
plus souple en sortant des
réglementation rigide qui crée toujours
plus de dysfonctionnements et toujours
plus de des incitations pour le pouvoir
d'achat le premier ministre veut aller
vite
le déblocage de la participation
bénéfices la prime de 1000 euros dans
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
devraient figurer dans le budget
rectificatif 2007 présenté ce mercredi à
l'assemblée
le rachat des jours de rtt des comptes
épargne temps
deux mesures qui feront l'objet elle
d'une proposition de loi déposée par le
groupe ump
le 11 décembre au palais bourbon pour
les mesures liées au logement loyers
indexés sur les prix dépôt de garantie
n'excédant pas 1 mois de loyer
le gouvernement devrait les présenter
dans un projet de loi dans le courant du
mois
selon la ministre de l'économie et des
finances l'ensemble des mesures en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat représenterait
25 milliards d'euros est introduit dans
l'économie française
les fonctionnaires pourraient aussi
bénéficier de nouveaux calculs pour leur
traitement qui permettrait d'augmenter
leurs revenus des négociations
s'engageront le 17 décembre entre le
ministre du budget et de la fonction
publique eric woerth et les sept
fédérations de fonctionnaires c'est ce
qu'il leur a annoncé ce matin
cette nouvelle flexibilité mais
évidemment à mal les 35 heures pour les
ans cette souplesse est nécessaire à la
relance économique
pour d'autres c'est la remise en cause
un avantage acquis sans réelle assurance
sur le pouvoir d'achat avait comparé de
deux économistes c'est le débat de ce
soir sur les 35 heures avec il junca et
jean francois monier
depuis sept ans la durée légale du
travail pour tous les salariés est de 35
heures hebdomadaires
pour beaucoup d'employés sur l'a6
traduit par des heures supplémentaires
l'an dernier 37 % des salariés on nous
fait pour les autres il y a des jours de
repos compensateur les rtt
aujourd'hui dix millions de salariés en
bénéficient la conséquence c'est la
modération salariale
l'aménagement des 35 heures comme le
fait mander rtt par exemple sur est il
bon pour le pouvoir d'achat des français
sans nul doute puisque les gens qui vont
travailler plus on vieillit plus haut
ils vont aussi pouvoir dépenser plus je
crois qu'il ya pas de secret et cela
s'était bien des problèmes qu'on avait
dans le temps passé jusqu'à dix points
thor c'est que ceux qui voulaient
travailler plus ne pouvait pas ou alors
c'était même pénalisé c'était d'ici ont
dissuadé finalement les employeurs de
proposer des heures supplémentaires qui
profitent des monétisation de rtt ce
sera les gens qui effectivement à des
rtt dire que les intérimaires ils n'ont
pas les temps partiels non pas les
chômeurs n'ont pas les retraités n'ont
pas tous ces gens n'en profiteront pas
deuxièmement sur les heures sup mais ça
c'est pas du gain de pouvoir d'achat
c'est un leurre
c'est un ensemble ça en fait on
travaille plus pour gagner plus bc
rémois une des choses le gain de pouvoir
d'achat c'est la productivité c'est à
dire gagner plus
à travail égal deuxième question faut-il
sortir des 35 heures ont donné une bonne
idée et qu'on est la seule à l'avoir
c'est que c'est pas une bonne idée et
donc et donc les 35 heures on est le
seul pays à l'avoir fait aujourd'hui on
a reculé
on travaille trois semaines de moins
européenne par habitant s'est pas
vraiment moins qu'on avance plus vite et
en plus non seulement on a perdu de
l'activité perdue la richesse mais en
plus on a créé du stress dans les
entreprises
les 35 heures ont permis de créer des
emplois c'est un mensonge de dire que
les 35 heures n'ont pas permis de créer
d'emplois elles ont permis de créer 2
300 400 mille emplois ensuite les 35
heures sont au moyen pour les personnes
qui ont 50 55 ans au plus de rester au
travail les 35 heures ont permis une
efficacité plus grande une productivité
plus grands notamment par
l'annualisation du travail efficace ou
pas pour l'économie
le régime des 35 heures devrait être
profondément modifiée en 2008
les négociations doivent se dérouler
entreprise par entreprise et pour
financer le plan des deux universités
qui devaient déjà annoncé le
gouvernement vient de céder denis % du
capital d'edf pour un montant d'environ
3,7 milliards d'euros c'est une première
tranche
lancement aujourd'hui de la 23e campagne
des restos du coeur depuis leur création
en 1985 par coluche 1,1 milliard de
repas ont été distribués aux plus
démunis des restos du coeur qui
constatent que leur clientèle entre
guillemets augmente 5% de plus chaque
année avec de plus en plus de personnes
âgées mais aussi ceux que l'on appelle
les travailleurs pauvres c'est à dire
qu'ils ont des revenus mais qui ne leur
permettent pas de vivre
reportage en alsace christine beauce et
nicolas frehner les restos du coeur jlf
l on ne pensait pas s'y retrouver un
jour est pourtant arrivé il ya quatre
mois à strasbourg après une rupture
familiale
il vient deux trois fois par semaine ce
resterai ici avec d'autres accidentés de
la vie
pas évident car il travaille ont cédé
dès qu'on n'allait pas finir la fin du
mois je sais pas et que 600 euros on va
manger correctement jeu
c'est simple si gilles pison n'est pas
une exception
15 % des bénéficiaires des restos du
coeur seraient des travailleurs pauvres
actuellement nous avons surtout de gens
seraient pas venues se réfugiant les
chantiers retraités actuellement des
jeunes et des salariés pour des gens qui
sont ici mais malheureusement d'armes la
nuit soit en d hébergement de nuit ou
dans leur voiture
gilles fall on a connu ça la rue les
cages d'escalier pour quelques nuits
aujourd'hui il partage une chambre dans
un foyer pour 90 euros par mois il ne
perçoit aucune allocation vient de
terminer un cdd comme étalagiste et
traque toutes les offres d'emploi le
petit boulot enchaîné les petits boulots
c
c'est temporaire mais bon c'est pas une
porte de sortie non plus quoi peut pas
miser là dessus on peut pas prendre un
appartement pour pas on peut pas se
fixer un avenir avec ça pas dire je vais
m'en sortir avec ça gilles façon vient
de décrocher une formation
mais le spectre de la précarité est
toujours présent au tour de ségolène
royal à travers la publication de son
livre ma plus belle histoire c'est vous
chez grasset il évoque la campagne
présidentielle avec quelques savoureuses
anecdotes et quelques formules
assassines aussi à l'égard des ténors du
ps
thierry kurt et et frédéric basket
l'heure de sa vérité ségolène royal a
laissé passer l'avalanche littéraire du
critique pour livrer enfin sa version de
sa campagne dans ma plus belle histoire
c'est vous l'autocritique est rare mais
elle concède était préparé pour
l'élection présidentielle
j'étais préparé beaucoup plus qu'on ne
l'a dit mais sans doute moins qu'il ne
l'aurait fallu
ses premières critiques et les réserves
aux éléphants du ps lors de son
investiture par le parti elle se
souvient dominique strauss kahn et
laurent fabius ne font même pas semblant
lionel jospin a préféré assister au
spectacle de pierre perret préférant
sans doute les jolies colonies de
vacances
mais la vraie surprise fut la démarche
qu'elle entreprend entre les deux tours
elle révèle qu'elle a proposé à françois
bayrou d'être son premier ministre
il l'a vite pour en parler dit elle mais
là non non ne monte pas il ya du monde
dans la rue lui dit il j'ai françois
bayrou au téléphone il est là haut chez
lui et moi je suis en bas dans la
voiture raconte elle la ceni cocasse
françois bayrou la démo pour certains au
ps ces démarches si ne passe pas même
aujourd'hui premier ministre
non vraiment je pense que c'est c'est
c'était une erreur à l'époque et je
pense qu'il faut que ségolène royal se
rendent compte que c'est pas en donnant
l'impression de faire un tel grand écart
idéologique qu'elle pourra bâtir la
suite de son parcours politique
son avenir justement il est pour elle
sans ambiguïté si elle reste discrète
quant aux moyens d'y parvenir son
objectif reste 2012
les suites du procès d yvan colonna les
complices présumés du berger corse et
force de le disculper après l'avoir dans
un premier temps tous désigné comme
l'homme qui a commis l'assassinât
les six membres du comité du commando
aujourd'hui condamnés et qui donc ne
court plus de peine supplémentaire
reviennent sur leurs premières
déclarations qui tu as accusés eux-mêmes
dominique verdeilhan et jean-marc new
look qui a tué le préfet claude erignac
s'interroge toujours sa veuve
car aujourd'hui devant les assises de
paris il y un tireur de trop venu de la
centrale de lannemezan pire alexandrie
endosse le rôle de l'assassin
depuis octobre 2004 après avoir été
condamné à perpétuité
pierre alexandrie se dit être celui qui
tenait larmes en garde à vue il accusé
yvan colonna pour moi dit il c'était une
porte de sortie temporaire j'étais dans
la confusion un acte de lâcheté de
faiblesse yvan colonna écoutent
attentivement autre témoin autre
condamné alain ferrandi va moins vite au
but alors colonna l'interpellent
maintenant il faut que les choses soient
claires j étais où j'étais pas je sais
que tu es un homme d'honneur et pons
ferrandi si tu l'avais fait tu le
reconnaîtrai tu n'étais pas là et tu ne
faisais pas partie du groupe des brevet
d'innocence en contradiction avec le
dossier d'instruction
ça me paraît absolument incroyable que
l'on mette ce plus de cinq ans pour dire
que quelqu'un est innocent alors que
l'on est son meilleur ami c'est je peux
dire que dans ma carrière je n'ai jamais
vu ça l'acrobatie se retrouve devant un
dilemme quelle version croire celle qui
accuse avec détails durant la garde à
vue ou celle d'aujourd'hui qui
innocentent sans preuve mais sous
prestation de serment
et puis dans la nièvre le procès de
christian beaulieu s'est ouvert ce matin
cet homme de 57 ans est accusé d'avoir
violé et tué mathias quatre ans lors
d'une fête organisée par les jeunes
agriculteurs de moulins engilbert le
prévenu est arrivé vous venez de le voir
la tête cachée sous un casque et l'a
reconnu les faits il avait déjà fait
l'objet de deux enquêtes pour attentat à
la pudeur la suite de la sphère les
incendiaires d'un bus à marseille en
2006 où une jeune fille mama galedou a
failli mourir brûlé vive des gens
septembre deux mineurs âgés de moins de
15 ans au moment de l'incendié ont été
condamnés à huit ans d'emprisonnement
par le tribunal pour enfants de
marseille aujourd'hui six autres mineurs
sont jugés devant la cour d'assises des
bouches-du-rhône à aix-en-provence
ils ont entendu par visioconférence
témoignage de leur victime et de ses
souffrances pour donner une jeune une
deuxième chance l'armée et le ministère
de l'emploi ont mis au point un
programme d'accueil pour les 18 21 ans
encadrés par des militaires à la
retraite et des professeurs ils
réapprennent une formation de base et
les règles de la vie en commun il existe
aujourd'hui 22 centres en france
reportage dans l'essonne sylvain le
petit et marie cran depuis un mois pour
la deuxième section c'est tous les jours
comme ça bienvenue aux centres défense
deuxième chance de montlhéry âgés de 18
à 21 ans ils sont en échec scolaire et
deviennent des quartiers populaires des
filles et des garçons volontaires pour
une formation à la dure
voilà avant je vais plus tard ces
fainéants
il ya des choses qu'on voudrait pas
faire de la journée quoi chez nous et
que là on se lève à 5 heures 5 heures du
matin on va leur apprendre à se laver
on va leur apprendre à se raser on va
leur apprendre des basiques dire bonjour
monsieur le directeur ou bonjour
monsieur bonjour madame au revoir et
cetera des basiques pour vous c'est
naturel pour hausser ce n'est pas du
tout naturel
ils veulent travailler dans l'hôtellerie
le bâtiment ou la sécurité
ils ont quitté l'école sans diplôme à
leur programme remise à niveau scolaire
la formation va durer de 6 mois à 2 ans
selon les projets de chacun dirigé par
un colonel à la retraite
le centre supergrave jusqu'au moindre
détail sur iton ton index au milieu ce
jeune homme se prépare un entretien
d'orientation et pour la première fois
il enfile le costume officiel mais il
suffira simplement que tu te rases un
peu les potes parce que selon son projet
devenir chauffeur routier de classe ont
ravi les grands fonds c'est d'avoir mon
chez moi d'avoir famille
je suis loin un candidat sur trois
cracks avant la fin de la formation
mais pour ceux qui la termine il ya des
emplois à la clé comme pour katarina bon
goût chaque jour elle transporte des
tonnes de béton à 30 mètres de hauteur
c'est son premier emploi et elle gagne
1800 euros par mois pour la grande
fierté de son père les maps et des voix
c'est vraiment ça ou est-ce que c'était
pas ça sept entreprises à embaucher de
jeunes routière sortie de centres
défense deuxième chance comme catarina
ils sont aujourd'hui plus de 500 avoir
trouvé un emploi sur toute la france en
russie et la victoire du parti de
vladimir poutine aux législatives
inquiète l issue de la présidentielle de
2008 à laquelle il ne peut pas se
présenter le président actuel est assuré
de garder la haute main sur la politique
russe les pays occidentaux considèrent
que ce scrutin n'est pas démocratique
sur place à moscou laurent bouffier et
xavier lisez ça n'est pas sur son visage
que l'on peut lire la joie de la
victoire ou le plaisir d'un pelé vis en
visite cet après midi de rampeau
spatiale vladimir poutine sans aucun
état d'âme à rappeler que ces élections
étaient parfaitement logique
les russes n'accepteront jamais leur
pays s'orienter vers une voie
destructrices comme cela s'est vu dans
d'autres pays de l'ex union soviétique
comme prévu avec 64,1 % des voix russie
unie le parti du président est gratuite
concurrents
315 sièges sur 450 à la douma une
hégémonie quasi totale après l'entamé
par les communistes deuxième force
politique du pays
laminé l'opposition dénonce des fraudes
massives et parle d'élection salle ces
élections n'étaient ni libres ni honnête
alors moi je demande quelle élection
parce que ce l'était pas de l'élection
pour preuve garry kasparov présente
cette image prise par un téléphone
portable on peut y voir une militante du
parti russie unie bourrer une urne
sous les yeux de scrutateurs méprise ou
pas manifestations de l'opposition ou
pas le triomphe de vladimir poutine est
fatale pourtant au lendemain de ce
raz-de-marée
le suspense reste entier sur les
intentions du président russe
comment va-t-il arbitrer les terribles
lutte de pouvoir que se livrent les
différents clans du kremlin
comment va-t-il garder son influence
après les élections présidentielles du
mois de mars prochain
à toutes ces questions pour l'instant
pas de réponse mais un risque réel de
durcissement du régime et on retrouve
françois beaudonnet en direct de
bruxelles bonsoir françois alors on peut
dire que les occidentaux sont crom assez
sceptique réticents vendent sur les
résultats de cette élection
oui actuellement ici à bruxelles on voit
affluer depuis ce matin à un grand
nombre de réactions de deux pays
européens des réactions plutôt négatives
vous l'avais dit la plus virulente et
bien c'est celle de l'allemagne berlin
dit que les élections russes ont été ni
libres ni démocratique de son côté le
gouvernement britannique lui se dit
inquiet quant à la position française
est bien c'est peut-être la plus nuancée
parce que dans un premier temps le quai
d'orsay avait dit qu'il souhaitait que
toute la lumière soit faite sur ces
éventuelles fraudes électorales
et puis ensuite on a appris que nicolas
sarkozy avait appelé personnellement
vladimir poutine alors le kremlin dit
que c'est pour le féliciter
chaleureusement ce que l'elysée ne
confirme pas ce soir ce qui est sûr
c'est que quelles que soient les
positions officielles et bien les
réprimandes européennes ne seront pas
suivies d'effet pourquoi et bien parce
que l'europe a besoin de moscou sur le
plan diplomatique et sur le plan
économique
juste un exemple le quart du gaz naturel
que nous consommons en europe et bien
provient de russie
merci françois j'ajoute que ce soit pour
tout comprendre sur cette politique
russe ne manquaient pas à 23 ans
15' y sur la planète spécial russie
présenté par thierry thuiller au
venezuela hugo chavez pour la première
fois a connu un revers électoral un
véritable camouflet pour le président
dont la réforme de la constitution a été
rejetée lors du référendum dorothée
olliéric les anti chavez ont gagné le
peuple à 51% à rejeter les réformes
proposées par le président vénézuélien
dont le camp d'hugo chavez c'est un
silence à la hauteur du camouflet la
réforme visait à instaurer un état
socialiste et permettre la réélection
indéfinie du leader de la révolution
bolivarienne pour hugo chavez c'est donc
le premier revers électoral doublée
d'une humiliation personnelle pendant la
campagne pour le référendum
il affirmait que son règne allait durer
jusqu'en 2050
ce matin il a dû concéder sa défaite les
états je félicite mes adversaires sur
cette victoire nosotros dans notre camp
et nous sommes habitués aux lions une
bataille partis d'opposition
associations de droits de l'homme
cercle financiers ou étudiants ce sont
eux qui ont fêté bruyamment la victoire
dans les rues de karachi
il accusait chavez de dérive
dictatoriale
aujourd'hui l'opposition est galvanisé
mais hugo chavez toujours président pour
encore cinq ans à bali en indonésie
c'est d'environnement construit occupe
avec une conférence internationale sous
l'égide de l'onu jusqu'au 14 décembre
sur les changements climatiques et le
réchauffement dû aux gaz à effet de
serre dont beaucoup de pays les
habitants prennent conscience de
l'urgence de changer les habitudes assis
au danemark l'île de samsø et passer aux
énergies renouvelables grâce à
l'implication de tous
un exemple que les spécialistes du monde
entier suivent avec attention comme le
montre ce reportage de jérôme boni et
juliette rien
quand le vent souffle dans la petite île
danoise de samsø c'est de la bonne
chance les éoliennes tournent à fond dès
qu'elle entend les bouras bettina k r
rempli sa machine à laver dont le
courant est fourni par la turbine à
l'est son mari électricien qui a racheté
cette éolienne d'occasion 60 mille euros
le vent souffle à peu près 60% du temps
alors j'ai assez d'énergie pour ma
maison
onze éoliennes collective fournissent
toute l'électricité de cette ancienne
place forte des vikings furent nommés
aujourd'hui l'île verte
chacun des 4200 habitants a contribué
pour 5400 euros à l'édification des
éoliennes le monde les habitants nous
sommes seuls ont bien compris ils sont à
l'avant-garde dans l'île tout le monde y
va de sa contribution par exemple en
roulant au biocarburant fabriqué ici à
partir du col c'est rare le professeur à
la retraite nous explique que les
céréales sont pressés dans cette machine
pour produire le combustible écologique
les résidus font des galettes pour les
vaches
pensait-il modèle il y a même une
académie des énergies renouvelables
histoire de motiver encore plus les
habitants où est absurbe et dévêtue
aller nous devons être responsables de
nos propres actions
et je crois que nous sommes un bon
exemple du passage des combustibles
fossiles et de l'énergie des toques à
une gestion décentralisée des ressources
ou chaque citoyen est responsable voilà
si tous les terriens était aussi engagé
pour l'écologie que les habitants de
samsø on aurait moins à s'inquiéter du
réchauffement climatique citoyen
responsable c'est le cas aussi de notre
invité de ce soit avec nicolas à
contrôler ses meilleurs moments dans
l'émission vivement dimanche de michel
drucker l'occasion de la sortie d'un
double dvd
nicolas canteloup que nous allons
écouter dans quelques instants mais
avant nous allons voir à quel point vos
journées sont chargées et des marteaux
comme le montre ce reportage de nicolas
le marinier et didier robert non
artère sarkozy bernard laporte qui va
être croqués par nicolas canteloup ce
matin sur europe 1 ma femme elizabeth
est enceinte
non et si elle attend des quadruplés et
bien je double les adhérents du modem
chaque jour à 9 heures jean-pierre
elkabbach est à la fois la première
victime est le premier fan
chacun est caricaturé ségolène jack lang
va chacun les caricatures et
physiquement avant qu'ils trouvent
presque le ton et la voie pour la radio
comme pour ses spectacles nicolas
canteloup se nourrit de l'actualité
parmi la centaine de voix qui limite qui
est son favori ont sonné le chouchou
c'est flou c'est souvent la marionnette
a fait de la mariée mais penser c'est
souvent le le personnage le dernier-né
où on est content bon de montrer le
nouveau né voilà depuis 2005 son premier
spectacle au palais des glaces à paris
nicolas canteloup a enchaîné les
tournées multiplié les apparitions à la
télé on se demanderait presque quand est
ce qu'ils trouvent le temps de souffler
ben justement vous allez vous poser la
question monstre nicolas grande sort on
voit que vos journées soit extrêmement
peur jeu quand trouvez vous le temps
pour pour écrire ou le fait comme ça
spontanément vous avez des années en
gestion pour les entourer la chance
d'avoir une belle équipe des auteurs
performant et philippe caverivière
stéphane joly vivant longuet qui met
beaucoup sur le drucker sur la radio le
matin sur l'olympia pas sur les
spectacles et donc ça me permet de
pouvoir fournir un petit peu plus que de
normal peut-être alors quels sont les
favoris dans ce que vous que vous
croquez est-ce que c'est l'accent du sud
ouest et le débit très particulier de
bernard laporte côté ronchonchon dans un
jean pierre bacri au contraire la
satisfaction d'arriver à faire ségolène
royal ce n'était pas évident oui c'est
vrai c'est très con soit seul à bord dès
lors je suis je suis ravi car c'est une
femme qui est aux manettes du jt la
place david pujadas les choses avancent
en politique nous avons les analyses mon
nom mais les lélés voulait voir que l'on
aime bien c'est effectivement comme je
le disais tout à l'heure c'est les
nouveau nés les voix du sud ouest parce
que c'est ma région et que ça m'est plus
facile et j'ai pas grand mérite là
dessus et
voilà et puis suivre l'actualité c'est
de sortir de dénicher une nouvelle voie
comme un chasseur mais alors justement
est ce que je fais douste-blazy vous
vous manque parce que vous êtes le seul
à reproduire cette fille d'accent comme
sa silhouette chic et vous le connaissez
bien cet accent mais oui bien la jupe
est celui-ci le plus au gouvernement
mais je suis sûr qu'il rebondira sur une
action majeure demain miss aquitaine où
l'élection plus locale à la maison
l'élection de qui sort le chien ce soir
et d'oust et douce quand je vois les
images de chine et se rappelle de
nombreux souvenirs quand j'ai vu le
premier ce chinois jackie chan et sa
femme suzy one tout ça c'est un des
grands souvenirs sirach vous n'avez pas
voulu imiter alors de rattraper
oui oui alors chirac j'avais une grosse
lacune j'avais du mal à imiter jacques
chirac donc là je me rattrape un petit
peu sur sarkozy qui nous donne pas mal
de grain à moudre mais si si j'ai un
petit message à lui lui adresser c'est
que c'est qu'il laisse parler ses
ministres parce que sinon c'est la fin
d'un petit métier comme le mien c'est si
on les entend pas et oui voilà vous avez
pas vous entraîner alors justement
qu'est-ce qui est le plus
qu'est ce qui nous met sur la piste
c'est le débit la mimique l'apparence
physique qu'est ce qu'ils ont un truc
deux choses l'une soit soit une voix
vient tout de suite j'ai pas grand
mérite
ou alors c'est un petit peu de travail
sur sur vidéo et puis s'il est vraiment
il faut s'intégrer s'imprégner du
personnage rentrer dans le personnage
physiquement j'ai bien à travers la
bouche en particulier si un de villiers
en mai à poussent de travers c'est sûr
mais une bouche [ __ ] rousset pour 2001
c'est une ceinture qui prend très à
l'aise par les affairistes rim
voilà c'est ensuite mais cas si je suis
élu me comme ça vous savez qui c'est je
suppose
oui bon donc voilà la mimique permet de
rentrer dans la peau du personnage et ed
comment vous fait pour pasticher tous
les matins l'interview que jean pierre
elkabbach vient de réaliser
est-ce que parfois d'ailleurs certains
de ses invités se formalise pas parce
que des fois vous avez la langue non
jean pierre est un petit peu peur que
les gens ne viennent plus en tant
qu'invité politique parce qu'ils étaient
pastiche est juste derrière et puis en
fait ils le prennent plutôt bien tant
qui a pas d' attaques physiques et qu'on
attaque juste sur le contenu sur ce
qu'il raconte c'est toujours supportable
est-ce que vous travaillez en ce moment
à créer de nouveaux personnages vous
venez de lancer un appel à présent dans
république il ya de nouveaux personnages
dans le spectacle
bien qu'on veut et christophe hondelatte
et puis rachida dati alors la mimique
d'arachide hâtif et maintenant la voix
de rachida dati puis si vous attendez et
cotisent concernant la justice n'y a pas
de problème qu'est ce que je vous dise
oui faut laisser parler les ministres on
a compris on l'a compris merci nicolas
je trouve que jonas est bien placé je
vais vous donner note je donne deux des
douze 12 pourquoi très simplement parce
que vous me citez 12 soit de censure
journal le chemin pour avoir 19 n'est
pas loué trois choses d'abord merci
beaucoup dit que la javel donc outre la
sortie de votre dvd vous serez à
l'olympia à partir du 14 avril pour
trois semaines
et puis football dure soit pour
strasbourg lors de la 16e journée de
ligue 1 a écrasé à lyon au stade gerland
5 à 0 avec notamment un doublé
les quatre hommes et un but de benzema
olympique lyonnais reste premier au
classement général avec 37 points alors
que les strasbourgeois ont chuté à la
13e place
je vous rappelle le principal titre de
cette édition avec ce voyage nicolas
sarkozy en algérie ce soit elle a
considéré que la colonisation était
contraire aux principes fondateurs de
notre république liberté égalité
fraternité on écoute
oui le système colonial a été
profondément injuste contraire aux trois
mots fondateurs de notre république
liberté égalité fraternité
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi avec nicolas
canteloup tout de suite la météo de
laurent romejko 20h50 col caisse 23h40
sur la planète autour de tirer du lit et
de la russie demain matin dans les 4
vérités jean marie cavada très bonne
soirée sur france 2 rois
m
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr votre soirée sur